to present the award for outstanding
achievement in film editing Harry Hamlin
from the motion picture making love and
the lovely Percival Anders
making films like making love is a truly
collaborative art but the spotlight
really shines of the men and women who
can make or break a picture of film
editors they take the bits and pieces of
film and bring it all together with the
skill of a surgeon a film editor can
save a bad film improve a good one and
elevate a great film to sheer artistry
the five films nominated by their peers
for best achievement in film editing are
Terry Rawlings for Chariots of Fire
Robert wolf for on Golden Pond
for Raiders of the most
Beauty Alan and Craig McKee for Red's
and the winner is
I wish to thank the Academy members for
giving me one of the great greatest
experiences of my life now what a
marvelous opportunity it was to work in
the same film together with Steven
Spielberg and George Lucas I'm
especially grateful to Steven for making
me part of his team and giving me such
superb film to work with and to George
Lucas for his very special help and warm
friendly support my thanks to Frank
Marshall our producer and our executive
producer Howard Kazanjian and to my
terrific English and Hollywood
assistants and of course to my patient
family finally I'm extremely happy that
the editing contribution on Raiders has
played an important part in your
enjoyment of the movie thank you for
this wonderful honor